hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that loves you no matter if you're
a human a zombie a vampire or lichen or
somewhere in between as long as you rock
a leather coat and stick that superhero
landing you're welcome here on versus
and today it's a monstrous multiplex
matchup that will pit two of the most
fervent fan based franchises of this
millennium against each other because
it's underworld dueling against resident
evil in one corner you have the kate
beckinsale-led film franchise known as
underworld it's he's her star is celine
an ass kicking like in dispensing death
dealer with some vampirical tendencies
in the other corner it's the mila
jovovich led video game adaptation
series called resident evil which sees
her star as alice an ass kicking
zombie-demolishing one-person army whose
doppelgangers are not to be messed with
either but this is versus and i will
mess with both of these celebrated
properties both are super successful but
only one will triumph by winning the
program the critics call a show and
quote something to watch and quote my
son hosts it hi mom here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
round three
villains round four high score and then
we'll do a wild card round that might be
all in slow motion at normal speed these
movies might be like 38 minutes long but
they're jam-packed with action attitude
and ass hickory did i mention ask
hickory already remember back in the old
days when all we had to worry about were
lions and tigers and bears oh my
but we're not in kansas anymore now it's
lichens and zombies and vampires holy
crap bring your heart strap on some
courage implant a brain and oil will be
a precious commodity in these worlds
gladiators ready
let's get it on round one box office far
be it for me my mom's third favorite
television host to spoil anything about
what's to come in today's episode of
versus right off the bat but here's your
fair warning our two film franchises
will have a much better time in this
round than they will when they enter the
tomato patch but hey before you can be
wrecked by the critics you gotta at
least be released in theaters resident
evil bowed first and it was way back in
2002 when mortal kombat film legend paul
w anderson directed mila jovovich in the
inaugural resident evil which was also
an adaptation of a hugely successful
video game that fan base came out in
full force to witness the big screen
debut of alice and the movie raked in
over 100 million dollars worldwide on a
budget of just 35 million bucks and from
there no other resident evil film would
ever fall below 125 million dollars at
the box office meanwhile the first
underworld was released the next year
and it nipped on the heels of resident
evil celine and friends took a 22
million budget and totaled 96 million
dollars with it around the world
underworld evolution from 2006 an
awakening would eventually surpass the
100 million dollar mark at the movies
with awakening being the high bar for
the underworld franchise earning 160
million dollars around earth 2009's rise
of the likens and 2016's blood wars both
the juke k to themselves just fine thank
you as they took in over 80 million on
each outing but there's just something
about alice and that pesky umbrella
corporation resident evil apocalypse and
extinction were the next two movies
released under that banner or umbrella
and they both did 125 million dollars
and then 150 million dollars
respectively so if they called it quits
after three flicks it would be
underworld that would have the highest
grosser of any film in either franchise
but they kept making those resident evil
films and with good reason paul w s
anderson you know can i just call him
paul anderson for the show he's my
favorite paul anderson that directs
movies did i just come up with a great
verses episode
anyway he returned for the fourth entry
in the series called afterlife and it
crushed it the cineplex to the tune of
295 million dollars across the globe
retribution would follow up taking in
240 million bucks and then the final
chapter until another book is written am
i right broke barriers no other film
we're talking about today can brag about
314 million dollars in 2016.
wow a sub 4 minute mile 600 touchdown
passes or the sixth film in your
franchise crossing 300 million dollars
look they're all great athletic
achievements but only one involved me
getting to indulge in movie theater
quality popcorn no offense to you
microwaves resident evil wins the
individual film grand total and it
doesn't lose much momentum when we look
at averages the six films have notched a
combined
1.22 billion dollars making for an
average atm withdrawal of 204.5 million
dollars per flick it's an imposing
number for even the most celebrated of
film properties to match and underworld
just can't climb to those heights but
those four films still did over 500
million dollars of total business making
for a solid 108 million dollars per film
here's the best news for either studio
behind this magic it only cost you about
43 million dollars to make one of these
so you know let's keep it going for
today in the here and now it was a nice
effort by celine and her vampire cronies
but allison the red queen and you know
all those zombie hordes proved to be too
powerful of a force resident evil wins
round one and goes up one to nothing
round two tomato meter slash audience
score and now it's time to see what the
critics had to say about these two film
franchises with hardcore fan bases let's
dial up the tomato meter first or as i
like to refer to it in situations like
this
let's just rip the band-aid off it's not
going to be pretty but there is a light
at the end of this rotten tunnel and
that would be the audience score but to
get there we're all gonna feel a little
like andy dufresne crawling through that
tunnel to escape prison who wants to go
first all right well resident evil you
have the honor so here we go the book
ends of this property 2002's resident
evil in 2016's the final chapter earned
36 and 37 respectively on the tomato
meter and that's the best news the
sandwich meet in between would be even
more rotten extinction afterlife and
retribution all fell into the 20
percentiles and apocalypse the second
film released in the series set the low
bar at just 19
there's no other way to say it
yikes the six films averaged just 27.6
on a tomato meter and let me do some
quick math here yeah that's going to be
rotten but don't worry resident evil
lovers you're not matched up against the
godfather trilogy here all you have to
do is beat the team you're playing and
that squad ain't exactly fresh either
underworld in its five movies can't even
get up to those lofty high numbers of 36
or 37 percent the first underworld is
the standard bear for this property and
it's only 31
and to make matters tougher for the neck
biters and the wolf folk their lowest
rated movie is an even tinier number
than resident evil apocalypse underworld
evolution devolves into just a 17
on the tomato meter in another word
still yikes the rest of these films all
found the 20 range making for a perflic
average of just 24.8 percent okay okay
that's enough rottenness for really
three or four episodes of this show so
i'll just remind y'all that milo
jovovich was great in the fifth element
which is fresh at 71
and kate beckinsale was marvelous in
serendipity which is of course at what's
that 59
oh come on the gloves match and the book
and okay well she was in the aviator and
that's at 86 so they're super fresh
performers that's the point but these
movies let's check out the audience
score
hey it's better news even within the
context of underworld and resident evil
in fact every underworld movie is fresh
on this metric with the lone exception
of the most recent effort blood wars
which landed at 49
underworld the og is at 79 percent and
evolution is hit 72 percent making for a
franchise average of 65 percent on the
audience score hey that's fresh way to
go team death dealer over in raccoon
city allison pals also enjoyed some
freshness on the audience score as the
first resident evil climb to 67 percent
and its immediate sequel apocalypse
squeaked into the hot tub at 60 percent
even well done the problem is to quote
eddie murphy's james brown it was too
hot in the hot tub and none of the
following four ra films made it back to
freshville extension got the closest
clocking in at 58 which if you're
keeping score at home is one below
serendipity all told the resident evil
films are fresh adjacent at 55.3 percent
per flick so when evaluating both film
franchises based on two metrics gauging
quality which one do we lean towards
well again we're not talking about
all-time critical darling movie sets
like the godfather toy story or the
expendables and i'm sorry i'm just now
being informed that i might have
overestimated the expendables but
regardless resident evil and underworld
seem to be by fans for fans and aiming
their stories that way has paid off in
the form of loyal enthusiasts that get
rabid about their appreciation in chat
rooms and it does help underworld that
it's at least fresh somewhere the
audience score turns the tide and in a
close round two it's the fighting beckon
sales that pull out the win and we're
tied at one round a piece
round three villains
i can't say enough good things about the
stars of these two franchises resident
evils mila jovovich and underworld's
kate beckinsale and they can act kick
ass and they don't seem too fazed by
classic movie monsters and while they
both score massive points with me for
being the clear leaders of these two
film series at some point you gotta
wonder why they keep coming back
it's villains in these worlds there's
always another scarier more powerful
batty than the previous one to take down
so let's see who had the taller mountain
of undead blood and guts to scale we
really get two types of villains across
these dueling universe landscapes you
got your classy well-dressed highly
educated hannibal elector types they use
proper grammar and prefer five-star
restaurants and oh yeah they're also
murderous sadistic psychopaths then we
have the purebred monsters who only
exist to kill what they lack in
intelligence they make up for in deadly
quickness and devastating power kind of
like a xenomorph and i know i know peta
is going to send an angry letter that
the face huggers from alien are actually
very smart and i should respect them but
look what can i say i'm more of a
predator guy resident evil spots as
great versions of both these villainous
archetypes jared harris harris's ashford
and ian glenn is isaacs they lend a
debonair hand to the foul play that
quickly ensues and both thespians seem
to have a blast in doing so isaac's is
revealed to be the true virtuoso in the
realm of evil genius for the movie
apocalypse meanwhile ashford at least
had the noble effort out of the gate of
trying to save his daughter's life
that's why he created the t virus but uh
yeah not quite as good in practice as it
was on paper it's tough to trust any
corporation that goes by the term
umbrella and that's especially the case
if it's headed by sean roberts's
character wesker after an attack on
tokyo and afterlife he strips alice of
her power and the two have one of the
best fights in the entire franchise dr
isaacs who creates super zombies and
becomes a monster himself after oding on
the good old t virus and extinction
continues to be a spiky thorn in the
side of alice throughout the films but
enough about doctors who kept their
fingers crossed while taking the
hippocratic oath let's look at some
impossibly well-dressed blood suckers
everyone please welcome back to the show
mr bill nye i feel it on my fingers i
feel it in my toes yes he was also a
raucous rocker in love actually but here
he plays victor the silver medalist of
all vampires and a pretty conniving
strategist in underworld he has all
sorts of foul play plans that meddle in
celine's death dealing not the least of
which is framing lichens while he does
his dirty work too but let's be clear
lycans are werewolves and not all that
nice to simple humans like you and me
but they can class up a dinner party
enter michael sheen before he was david
frost grilling richard nixon he was
lucian in underworld the leader of the
likens just look at that devil may care
smile any time some carnage is about to
ensue but what i love about underworld
evil doers is that they can transition
from classy to full-on universal classic
movie monsters so seamlessly including
the doctors check out steven ray's dr
jacob wayne who's also a menacing
werewolf team jacob indeed he's featured
in awakening alongside his son quint who
is a super lichen originally he wanted
to go by the name uberwolf but sadly he
doesn't own a toyota prius a driver's
license or a candy dish but i'd still
give him five stars just for being the
scariest of all the lycans pivoting back
to the world of vampires let's check in
on how marcus's awakening is going
yeah he's back and sexier than ever tony
curran plays this role in the first
sequel in underworld war provides one of
the most menacing fang presences in the
entire series and really elevates the
stakes oh come on vampires are hundreds
of years old they love dad jokes back on
resident evil street we have a lot to
deal with if nefarious physicians
weren't enough we also have outright
monsters and some of our good folks that
get turned into
well outright monsters not you dr isaacs
i was thinking more of michelle
rodriguez is reign ocampo who turns into
a zombie at the worst possible time when
alice and maddie ball game are battling
a liquor you heard me right it's a
liquor with a tongue that would make
gene simmons feel insecure am i wrong
for feeling sorry for this monster when
alice stabs his licking apparatus maybe
it's because i bit my tongue mistaking
it for a milk dud earlier in the movie
anyway matt and alice prevail but i did
warn you matt gets turned into a nemesis
a mutated super soldier in the very next
film the thing about these movies is our
heroes usually win the day but man are
those victories short-lived there is no
off-season especially when instead of
celebrating at disneyland you have to
battle zombies zombie crows zombie
dragons zombie dogs oh they're still
cute i kind of want one and the axe man
no not legendary ozzy osbourne guitarist
randy rhodes an actual axe-wielding
psychopathic monster dude shows up in
both afterlife and retribution my
highlight is when ally larder's claire
slides under him ricky henderson's style
and pops him right in the sweet spot
it's a battle in afterlife that in real
time probably took three seconds but as
i mentioned wow to these movies love
them some slow motion
but what keeps me coming back to the
underworld films is the personality and
emotional weight that their sets of
baddies have sure we have tons of
underwing vampires and werewolves to
dispense of but at the top you almost
want to buy into the cult of being an
undead monster it looks fun and that
blue instagram filter they use for these
movies will take 10 years off your age
bill nye's victor is deep down a
tortured soul who would even sacrifice
his own bloodline to keep vampires pure
michael sheen's illusion is a cunning
trickster who is an expert at keeping
the monster within at bay until it's go
time william or as i call him billy the
wolf was the first werewolf and has a
fascinating storyline in evolution and
the most recent underworld flick blood
wars gave us a memorable trio of
opposition samira a next level vampire
marius leader of the likens and varga a
death dealer whose stats definitely get
him into the all-star game resident evil
also features surprisingly deep
emotional resonance as well but the
zombie hordes and their many animalistic
variations never feel quite as fresh as
a new crop of coffin nappers hairy full
mooners and death slingers in a close
call i'm giving the edge to underworld
here and team beckinsale goes up two to
one round four high score
and here we are the round of rounds in
this action-packed nightmare-inducing
popcorn face stuffing contest because
when zombies werewolves vampires and
more leather than a montana fashion show
get together you're going to have some
memorable moments one's a video game
franchise so the high score here will go
to which property gave us the most
thrilling sequences stupefying stunts
and yes slow motion in the rain seattle
you're gonna love these movies release
the kraken
or in the case of resident evil the
final chapter a huge winged demon this
is an epic fight sequence from start to
finish and had notably better visual
effects than when the ogra was released
in the early 2000s but the final chapter
couldn't let us close the book without
bringing some fun from that inaugural
outing back for one more slice yep it's
that laser hallway thing a thrilling
scene back in 2002 that diced up a bunch
of alice's comrades a similar
contraption was used in the final
chapter some of the best moments in the
entire franchise are those close
quarters combat entanglements that
elicit equal parts suspense and
claustrophobia if you prefer your
corridor is more well-lit and less
laser-y resident evil has you covered in
retribution a highlight of alice's
penultimate flick is that battle where
she's slinging chains at nasties in what
appears to be an apple store except with
less geniuses and more monsters but as
both ras alice and celine from
underworld can attest if you slaughter a
bad guy but don't do a cool landing
immediately after did it really happen
at all kate beckinsale wastes no time in
underworld part one when she deals some
death and lands perfectly despite what
looks like a fairly restrictive costume
who has the better badass landing that's
a question not even a host of verses can
answer
my take is they should team up and do
synchronized swimming at the next summer
olympics a year before the same trick
was attempted in van helsing hey that's
came back and sale again celine was a
pioneer of the old shooting the four
with so many bullets that will allow a
fall below to a different floor to
escape danger gag it was such a fun
inventive moment that eventually
mythbusters gave it a shot and
apparently it works better in vampire
flicks as far as fight sequences go my
preferred underworld cinema would be a
tie between evolution and awakening in
evolution we see william werewolf
patient zero and marcus bloodsucker
extraordinaire both tango with celine
and one of the many highlights is when
she drives a truck through marcus and
although it only fails him for a few
moments that's still much better than
you or i would do in evolution celine
goes full rampage on the vamps and the
wolves including a scene where she
battles multiple hairy beasts in an air
shaft
john mclean could barely ignite a
lighter in the vents from die hard
if the force shooting magic trick is an
all-timer for underworld alice has a
counter in resident evil apocalypse she
knows how to make an entrance a little
fashionably late oh and she rams a
motorcycle through a church window it
really spices up those hymns doesn't it
it's the perfect mix of gritty grappling
and over-the-top action equally
impressive is mila jovovich doing most
of her own stunts as she runs down a
building in the same movie
years before daredevil had a hallway
fracas or atomic blonde iron cast
skilleted her way to a win in a kitchen
alice was showing us all how to make the
most of limited space
okay okay we love you both but now it's
time for last licks
sit down vampires i i meant the last
gasp for each team in underworld i'm
going for blood wars remember how i
mentioned how cool and imposing marius
the leader of the lykans was well maybe
to us but for poor celine this guy's
just practiced for her mortal kombat
finishing move she rips out his spine
are you kidding me toasty
okay okay that's the cake but the icing
is the lucian versus victor fight that
we've been waiting for it finally goes
down and rise of the likens and does not
disappoint it's a close battle here
alice you got any more tricks up your
sleeve even though like me you prefer
sleeveless shirts yes she does in
afterlife when once again the ghost of
john mclean is referenced underworld had
an air shaft resident evil gave us alice
bruce willising her way off a building
top on a bungee cord to avoid a zombie
horde the only issue she swings down
then swings sideways and it looks really
cool and she manages to land right in
the middle of you guessed it another
zombie horde she caps a bunch of them
then barry sanders is her way through
the rest if extraterrestrials came down
to earth and wanted to see the most
resident evily moment in all of cinema
that's the scene we'd play for him
and then they'll say take me to your
leader and we'll show them to the red
queen good luck e.t
team owls wins this round and once you
know it we're tied at two to two and now
it's time for the wild card round legacy
what a matchup it's been so far and now
it all comes down to this round which
puts a ton of pressure on my 35 pound
dumbbell arnold pressing shoulders
that's on a good day i know kate beck
and salem and mila jovovich are watching
right now to which i just say hi kate
remember me the guy from punk'd
more on that in a minute for now we're
talking legacy both series have proven
to be blockbusters that have spawned a
hardcore fan base but which film
franchise has left a bigger mark on
cinema modern filmmaking and what has
the playbook for how to re-kill undead
things that have already been slayed the
best let's hit the bricks and on this
road by acknowledging how crucial both
film slates have been to cementing women
as leading ass kickers in hollywood
today i mean right now we're treated to
movies like black widow we get
characters like michonne cersei furiosa
and so many more but back in the early
2000s that wasn't the case trailblazers
like sigourney weaver's ellen ripley and
linda hamilton's sarah connor helped
pave a road that kate beckinsale and
mila jovovich would transform into a
bustling interstate the best part is
that we never need a convoluted
backstory to explain why these two
leading ladies have been forced into
these roles against their will or better
judgment taking on fleets of
mythological beasts may not be a
relaxing hobby but it's clear early on
in both resident evil and underworld
that alice and celine are right at home
when it comes to fantastical action
resident evil took the pioneering a step
further remember zombies well yeah sure
every other entertainment option these
days is some sort of undead lumbering
riff but back in the day zombie flicks
were not as bankable similarly the idea
of melding the war of vampires and
werewolves had been explored scarcely in
film and when it was a central plot
point it was usually found in parodies
like abbott castella meet the wolf man
or the horror comedy monster squad where
underworld separates itself as the
mythology continues to evolve and never
gets stale lycans and draculas are
underground and remain hidden from the
world at the outset of the franchise but
by the time blood wars happened you know
the fifth movie in the franchise humans
had become aware that these creatures
weren't just the stuff of fiction they
were walking amongst us and were in most
cases fashion icons resident evil took
good storytelling in a different
direction as it went global with the
locations before the final chapter
brought alice right back to square one
to face off against the red queen and
the umbrella folk within the friendly
confines of raccoon city two diversion
strategies but both help set the
template for other sci-fi horror or
action temples to take a cue from but
whereas underworld built on our
affection for classic movie monsters
resident evil faced a more modern
challenge how the heck do you make a
horror themed video game into one hit
movie much less a billion dollar
franchise mortal kombat again directed
by the best paul anderson was a modest
hit back in 1995 but par for the video
game movie course had been duds like
street fighter and double dragon props
to angelina jolie for breaking that
video game flick glass ceiling with her
tomb raider double feature but resident
evil had an even higher hurdle to leap
over this wasn't a family friendly
swashbuckling adventure this was
visceral gory intense horror that wasn't
going to pander to the mpaa or anyone
else the source material mandated that
the movies based on it would have to be
rated r and the crew did not shy away
from this perceived barrier underworld
also embraced the r-rated challenge and
did so with profitable results but the
reason i leaned towards resident evil is
the groundbreaking work it did in terms
of global box office appeal this was one
of the first film properties to lean
into its worldwide audience realizing
that just because american audiences
alone may not make this a gigantic smash
money talks all over earth the final
chapter almost grossed as much as rogue
one a star wars story on its opening
weekend in china which is all the more
noteworthy because films featuring
supernatural elements rarely show up in
that market additional points go to
alice for sharing the wealth with other
significant female badasses like ali
larter wee bingbing and michelle
rodriguez
i consider myself a converted fan of
both franchises having initially scoffed
at vampirical action and a video game
adaptation but i have come to realize
both film sets have a ton to offer in
terms of a plus action some surprising
emotional depth and considerable legacy
but if it's this close i gotta go with
the film that came first and proved how
potent video games can be as movie
franchises resident evil edges
underworld in this round does that cool
superhero landing thing and wins today's
match and now back to that punk story
your ridiculous host wasn't always the
hugely successful ford fusion owner that
he is today
it's elise back when i was just a young
comedian i booked some jobs on mtv's hit
prank show punk'd and my first mark was
none other than kate beckinsale if we
have the footage you'll see me plus 30
pounds two extra chins and some stellar
curly hair she mistakenly thought i was
the guy who is hitting on her and when
she described the incident to our
accomplice michael sheen he fake rage
pushed me into a pool is payback
i wasn't particularly memorable for
anything i did but it was a super fun
day and she was so nice afterwards so
sorry i couldn't get one of your great
characters a win today please apologize
to celine for me was resident evil that
gets my w today but that's just my
opinion now it's your turn world before
the lycans awaken and the apocalypse
brings about our extinction make your
boys heard and hit us up on social media
with your take i'm at mark ellis live
and i have not walked on the edge of a
pool fully clothed since that day on
punk thanks for watching versus i'm mark
ellis reminding everyone it wasn't the
lycans it was you
[Applause]
[Music]
you